yo it's crazy to think like
so much of what's going on in hip-hop
right now can really be traced back to
you influence-wise
all right people don't give me listen
let me tell you something when i hear
what's going on in jacksonville
when i hear what's going on in your
hometown
alabama i i hear so much of like this
all is
from boozy sonically a lot of this [__]
is
you started this [__] you know what i'm
saying as far i mean like wayne gets a
lot of credit and chief keith gets a lot
of credit but i'm like bro like
this [__] she made this gangster rap
[__] believable the pain
[__] talked about it and all that [__]
but i made this [__] believable
you know what i think you did too like
[__] don't give me that credit but i
made gangsta rap
this [__] believable like like [__] my
[__] went with every story
like [__] i made these [__] won't rap
about you know like but
i think you did a great job of like
actually introducing real pain
into your music like you know what i'm
saying like when he would hear
certain like album cuts from you'd be
like oh this [__] you feel that that
[__] hits different you know what i'm
saying right and it's the same pain in
the music
here now it's just people inflicted a
little bit
but i was really the first one talking
about
i wouldn't say the first one but i was
one of the ones who
who made you feel like i grew up with
you
mm-hmm like i was in the house with you
like you know i
i put [__] in tears i raised florida i
raised
all these states you know
gangster music i i raised a lot of i
raised a lot of states growing up
you just you feel like you get the
credit you deserve though i i i feel
like
i i get the realness i deserve i don't
get the credit i deserve i get the
realness and i'm happy with that
you know most people come up to me and
say they don't you're a real [__]
you know instead of [__] you're a fool
just rap [__] your food this
you know most people give me stripes on
being a real [__]